I think my favorite one it says here it
says my girl is a lawyer and that one's
really cute yeah remember back in March
when Kim Kardashian dished on all the
tattoos her then boyfriend Pete Davidson
had Inked on his body for her yes well
now it looks like Pete might be erasing
all traces of their relationship from
his body but a source tells E.T not so
fast we'll just have to wait and see the
Saturday Night Live Alum was spotted on
the set of his upcoming peacock series
bobkus rocking a tracksuit t-shirt and
sneakers but all eyes were on Pete's
neck check out that bandage poking
through his shirt very close to where he
had my girl is a lawyer Inked in honor
of Kim naturally that got the internet
all of us with fans speculating he had
that sweet body art removed oh my God
but now a source close to the actor is
setting the record straight telling ET
quote while he continues to remove his
tattoo use that image is from set and
not related to removing the lawyer
tattoo what's going on of course Kim and
Pete started dating last year after her
appearance on SNL Are You Gonna Kiss Me
Or Not I sure am Jasmine
shortly after that this game's founder
finally passed the baby bar exam after
several unsuccessful attempts which
inspired that lawyer Tad but it wasn't
the only tribute Pete had etched on his
body for Kim he was like I want
something that's there I don't want to
be able to get rid of it or to cover it
up and I just wanted it like there as
like a scar on me yeah he literally had
her name branded on his body he's just
super genuine I love that he's kind and
really really thoughtful he's the most
thoughtful person and I love the
chemistry that Kim and him have together
it's really sweet I thought you said the
chemistry I was like okay chemistry
chemistry well that chemistry fizzled
out and the two called it quits back in
August after nine months together it is
what it is a source recently told ET
that the comedian is bummed about their
split but is trying to stay focused and
positive quote he had has the utmost
respect for Kim her kids and the family
he wants to maintain a healthy
relationship with all of them what kind
of man at this point in your life do you
see yourself with
absolutely no one as for Kim she
recently revealed she's in a phase of
life where she's working on herself I'm
not looking for anything I think I
really just need to be by myself in
focus and finish school so law school my
kids yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you